[Music]
um what say again what was the question
the F stuff what about it
the yeah you said heated debates yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was around that time
but it wasn't really that it was like
after that because after all the Fest
stuff the air had like shifted and like
the community started to dislike
revisionist history is Crazy K gringle
oh gringle oh my God what do you do do
you post with very little to no push
back people just believe all the things
that he said about you if it's a cult do
you think these people are brainwashed
you're speaking about them like they're
knowingly you're calling them pieces of
[__] and you're speaking about them so I
I I do believe that Destiny is has no uh
Illusions about what he is doing and who
he is but Dan comes across to me like a
True Believer like he I agree he is
sabotaging Destiny in a way but it seems
like he can't stop himself like he feels
deeply emotionally driven he fell asleep
I think he fell asleep on J Stock's
stream the other night just to try to be
there to prevent me from talking about
Destiny and I think in a way he's trying
[Music]
that is true Knox okay if my Google
accounts leaked all right listen I they
leaked okay my only fans my fley my
secret patreon my Twitter NSFW account
what else do I have my Tik Tok where I
promote all of that content to a 13 plus
platform because that's that's a good
thing to do by the way all the women
that promote their porn on a platform
that's like mainly inhabited by children
they're good all right it's good that
they're doing that
okay for $25 I'll hide it all thank you
all right fans Le on
Twitch oh and the Fur Affinity yes where
I where I what is the what is the furry
equivalent of lli is it UB UB where my
all my Cub is right guys you feel me
common experience I'm sure I don't
private this VOD I'm going to watch it
later hey no promises all right oh he
just started huh it didn't I want to
hear what he has to say hello um what
he's being dude he's being gangst uh it
didn't feel it didn't feel Jesus I think
um I have these sit to stand desks and
they're hand
cranked um and I was I wanted to lower
the boom a little bit and I think it got
caught on something and then it just
like released I don't really know what
it was I don't know what happened Jesus
anyway call in I thought about calling
in little on it but I I literally don't
have anything to say I don't have
anything to
say I don't I really don't I would love
to to call in and and you know maybe ask
a question or two but I I really don't
know what to say Destiny is a big fan of
hand craking so I've been told so I've
been told I don't know I don't have
anything I would ask I would have to
like prepare something and I wouldn't I
I I wouldn't know what to
ask thank you godspeed for the Canadian
20 yes yes yes yes thank you godspeed
thank you thank you vile Dono sound give
me more money to hear it more all right
that's what I have to say to that all
right awesome stuff happening Edge um I
thought that the intro I know the
thumbnail and the stream title are very
funny very funny Max very funny um but I
thought that it would not be appropriate
sunglasses I still where to launch but
sunglasses the music the intro the
ashery didn't seem appropriate uh for
this stream I love watching Mar live
thank you thank you so much all right 60
of 60 of my my most loyal viewers here
today Jimbo slice I recognize you Zack
Ed Zach I think you're I think you're
one of the the few the few main Channel
viewers that actually enjoys the live
streams because I've seen a few I've
seen a few main Channel viewers trickle
in all right trickle into the live
streams I don't know how they find me
but they do they trickle in and they're
like oh my God I don't like this guy I
don't like this guy this guy is evil
this guy's vile right 2023 viewer as
well Jesus you need to find a better use
of your time watching me for a year holy
[__] Jesus Christ all right but you you
are one of the few it seems that enjoy
the main Channel content all right which
is interesting okay I listen I
cultivated an audience of very soy uh
LGBT woke libtard retards essentially on
the main Channel and it's very
interesting that you're the one that
stuck around for everything
okay awesome stuff I uh I've been kind
of wrestling with how to talk about this
I've never seen a main Channel video
you're not missing out I've made some
pretty strong statements condemning the
statements of orbiters distancing
themselves I feel like people are not
handling this responsibly I I think you
have to admit that even if you pushed it
out of your mind you you knew and now
you hate fboys and trans except Food
Shops because it's
AA yeah you knew that death engaged in
sexual misconduct and other of abuse and
manipulation and dishonesty you knew
he's got a great explanation or if
you're in the cult he's got a good
explanation for each each story but
everybody there knew we all knew anybody
who's worked with him eventually he
figured out and I think it's great that
they're stepping back cutting ties you
know condemning the behavior but I don't
like it when they condemn the behavior
but tiptoe around condemning the man and
uh I've gotten some push back about this
saying like well you know if they're in
a cult then you have to be super patient
with them you know they're they're
waking up they don't realize what's
going on and I think to some degree
that's true but you got to remember the
victims there are a lot of victims um
and and this past week we've learned
about two more it looks like compulsive
Behavior to me I wouldn't be surprised
if there were lots and lots more I don't
know but people are are looking to you
to the orbiters to anyone with a a loud
voice in the situation to make sense of
what's Happening hey puddle sucker I'll
pull up your socks in a bit okay I will
I'll pull them up I'll pull up the socks
all right they look awesome and um it's
it's everyone's disoriented cuz they've
been lied to Destiny is deceitful and
manipulative and so if you've been lied
to and you don't know you don't
understand the nature of the system or
group that you're in and you're
realizing it the orbiters are lying on
their way out they're still they're
still propping up the cult on their way
out and they shouldn't do that it's not
fair it's not fair to the victims it's
not fair to the the people still in the
cult to say well everything Destiny did
up until now is acceptable or
explainable but this is this this is
over the line when I think clearly what
is happening is what happened to me two
years ago is you eventually learn or see
something that changes your your Framing
and understanding of every that you have
seen it makes you realize that that you
knew you didn't know but you did we all
did if Destiny had been a guest on my
podcast he would not have lasted 5
minutes there is [__] I let Slide the
moment I mean a nonf famous Rich guest
if he was a hotline caller just some gu
calling him the hotline there is [__]
that I let slide in my first
interactions with him that I never would
have let slide or if you told me if you
just introduce me randomly to a rich
powerful guy and then a woman says hey
he abused me this is Anna an an com I
meet her at the same time she says this
guy me and the guy says oh ignore her
she's a stalker am am I didn't even look
into it I asked him about it I said hey
I'm concerned I'll ask the rich powerful
Guy Mr Weinstein okay well he's he is
framing like come on all right come on I
would personally you know try and talk
to both of the parties involved I
learned the act of reacting from queman
what the you want me to [__] PA like
he hasn't even gotten a thought out dude
I'm like waiting for him to actually say
something so I can [__] have like
some comment on it all right he's a very
slow talker you want me to [__] pause
every 5 seconds and I'm like you know
the lighting the lighting at the back Mr
girl hotline you know it's like an it's
it's an allegory one of the colors is
pink and the other is sort of a teal
blue you can see it's a back blackground
you can see and also he has a he has a
he has a standing desk hand cranked this
is a metaphor for how Mr girl views
societal Norms now if you also look at
the microphone he's using there is no
seems to be no foam
cover now you can also see the the cord
the cable for his his microphone is also
hanging
free Additionally you can see the Mr
girl is wearing a black shirt signifying
what he feels like on the inside is that
what you [__] want hellbent is that
what you [__] want are you going to
cover mantis accusing spicy chhat of
violating her consent post it in the
[__] Discord stupid [__] [__] you
all right you [__] cover something
put it in the Discord or DM me godamn it
all right I'm going to react how I'm
going to react and listen if you don't
[__] like it listen to me
[__] if you don't [__] like
it laric is live Nick diorio's probably
live all right go watch someone else
stupid [__] find it yourself I'm going
to bed yeah I don't want you here
anyways good [__] riddance good
[__] riddance dude [__] you all right
bro go live go live nobody else is
watching and then the moment I go live
I'm going going to bed I hate this
stream react harder I'm going to bed
[__] off [__] off [__] off dude is is
Ashley Jud telling the truth about you
but he said no I talked to him I was
very concerned I talked to him if I had
been maybe I'll post your sexual
harassment DMS before I go to sleep yeah
the ones with you or the countless other
women I DM because you're not
special the day before I met Destiny and
my clone had been locked in a glass cell
hanging from a big tree above my life
that's watching my life what do you
think he would have thought of that
moment I knew I knew I'll C listen HB
Ben okay hey first time viewer here in
the jstock waiting room what does that
mean you're in the jstock waiting room
you're not in the jto what are you
talking about who are you what well
thanks thanks for stopping by hellbent
listen if you want me to look at the the
Manta stuff I was going to anyways but
if you'd like me to look at anything
specific you can DM me all right
otherwise I'm probably just going to
scroll through her TW
and look at what she's been saying okay
sorry for being so mean I didn't mean it
all right sorry hell then if you if you
want me to look at the Mantis stuff you
can DM me the tweets you want me to look
at all right sorry I knew I knew and I
took the money we all did I understand
it's a little more complicated for you
guys because you were also fans of
Destiny I was never a fan of Destiny so
I had the advant K and by the way in the
chat over here of seeing through
people's [__] I may have a
superpower of being willing to say it
out loud when it will be very costly to
me yeah I have that power but I was just
dropped into the center of a cult the
cult happened to find me very compelling
maybe because I'm kind of like the cult
leader or kind of like the way the cult
leader pretends to be so I found myself
near the top of a power structure uh but
with no intrinsic affection of or or
loyalty to the leader I mean I the
Loyalty I did feel and the love I felt
and the trust I placed it in him was the
result of feeling like he believed in me
or took me under his wing and and helped
me and helped my angry exploding
followed by love bombing typical all
right buddy come on come on work that
meant a lot to me obviously but I had
the benefit of being it's like it's like
if you walked into a Scientology church
and then you got promoted to level 200
or whatever on day one um with no
indoctrination and no need for it no no
like I have I have some stuff I'm
addicted to but it's not watching
streams I never watch streams I never I
never watched streams before you never
watch streams I still don't I don't like
watching streams I get anxious and I
compulsively watch them they're about me
but I don't like watching them so that
benefited me a lot so so it's easy to
see what's happening when you have
skipped the indoctrination phase same
thing with Dr K I had the benefit of
being a psych major and then it with a
family who are psychologist and then
being dropped in the center of a
situation that I never would have
otherwise stumbled into there's no
gradual introduction to the weird oh
this is this just how the space is yeah
I'm like well the space is [__] up and
you're all crazy and a lot of you are
[__] okay what not me though not me
though okay I'm incredibly intelligent
it's actually crazy we entertain Mr girl
at all shows how serious you all are by
Sticks grift foul crypto Hammer 666 why
shouldn't we take Mr girl seriously what
exactly has he done that you disagree
with or are you just like another person
who's like we shouldn't listen to Mr
girl and you don't actually have a
reasoning because you're [__]
[__] I'll wait for you to respond
all right I'll wait for you to respond
what exactly do you love about him
that's not the claim that you made why
shouldn't we take him seriously please
indulge me tell me don't come on don't
weasel out don't weasel out all right
don't weasel out you like the way he
treats
women why shouldn't we take Mr girl
seriously go ahead you keep you you
refuse to answer you refuse to
answer curious H I'll wait I'll wait I
will wait for you to respond why
shouldn't we take Mr girl seriously
smells thank you Alan appreciate it come
on you were a bit of a fan no you did
seem to really like him and seem to
think he was an interesting funny and
engaging person I've never watched a
destiny stream because I was interested
in what he had to say I don't even have
an account on his site I'm I'm not I I
did I had never my entire exposure to
Destiny was I I think someone sent me a
clip of him talking about my cu's review
which I watched in 2021 that was 3
seconds long and then I forgot that that
happened but uh so I I actually forgot
that happened but then later I saw a DM
from myself in 2020 or 2020 it was a
year before so I someone had told me he
existed so I knew his name but I didn't
I didn't remember that he like reacted
to the cuest thing um like for 3 seconds
and then uh that was it I didn't and
somebody was like oh you talk to Destiny
I was like oh he's I kind of know that
he's a guy I watched a stream of him
talking about uh trans people gender in
the shower all right listen big news
guys the mors came in mors came in and
it looks like the morow community is
really loving them all
right the socks people are loving the
socks all right people are loving the
socks listen Okay buy some go to the mor
live Channel there's a shopping section
buy your own rocks by your buy your own
socks all right
please all right while I was getting
ready to do my first stream with I just
tweeted him and he said sure let's talk
and uh that was it so I listened to his
argument in the shower and I was like
this guy does not believe the trans
women are women he's he's he's lying
he's pretending he thinks that to
protect his audience or protect his
career or whatever but I don't I think
this is [__] um which I basically
told him I said it in a very gentle way
that I normally wouldn't but that's you
know that's kind of what I'm trying to
cop to but no I was never a fan I was my
first my first inclination was that he
is interesting in terms of you know
picking apart thought experiments or
picking apart politics with thought
experiments um talented rhetorically uh
what else did you say engaging yeah very
engaging compelling charismatic but I
but that none of that made me want to
watch his content so that's I was a fan
I was say I met him and liked him I
think I did like his content I I watched
older stuff though I watched like the
JonTron debate I watched The Amos ye
discussion he had I watched a couple of
incest arguments he had and I thought it
was awesome I thought it was awesome I
was really interested in that um then I
tried to watch his like current content
and it was just a lot of like it was a
lot of like Israel Palestine [__] and I
just couldn't I just couldn't get into
it I could not give a [__] I could not
give a [__] about Israel Palestine to be
honest I really couldn't give a [__] so
did we did we miss a Dono we didn't okay
I don't know why never mind all right
we'll continue yeah I have small feet
should be fine thank you Kaye awesome
you certainly enjoyed the money he
helped you
make um I did I bought that sign um yeah
I enjoyed the money I think I enjoyed
the acceptance more than the money if I
had to choose between the two I'd
probably choose you know a large
audience societal semi- acceptance it'
be nice cuz when you're as vulnerable as
about your weirdness as I am getting
accept because it doesn't feel like it
it doesn't feel like oh I'm playing to
the crowd and it's working it feels like
I'm pouring my [__] heart out and
these people are reacting positively
yeah I enjoy that and the money I'm
making money for being hon I'm making
money for being honest about who I
really am all this this all these people
in my entire life telling me Oh you
don't say what you're really thinking
you have to learn to play the game I and
I didn't I just am saying what I really
think and I'm getting but alas I was
actually a sideshow freak and a sex cult
[Music]
oops what did he mean by this hm H rate
the hairline his hairline is fine okay
he doesn't have like listen I I would be
a little more concerned if he was widows
peing all right but he's not it's
probably just a maturing hairline he's
like 40 okay dude he's [__] 40 all
right Jesus Christ okay is your hairline
better than Mr girls
uh uh maybe I keep having dreams that I
go bald so I don't think that's good I
think I'm for telling something to
myself all right I think something's
going to happen to
me something's going to happen to
me not the job I I thought I was being
raced with so
yeah okay um let's let's get into the
calls I don't even know where people are
at now in 2022 was obvious you know
people were where they were but now I
have no [__] idea all right I'm going
to take the word drama out of my title I
don't know why but sing the word
drama I don't know if I uh I don't know
why but I don't like I don't like
calling this Destiny stuff drama
something about it is making me feel ill
I'm taking drama out all right for now
yeah I'm doing this I'm getting in the
office Destiny te Marathon maybe shirt
looks better I'm a linty shirt's not
dirty it's just linty I don't I wash all
my [__] together I don't got time for
you know how Einstein and Steve Jobs
just had the same outfit every day so I
don't have to think about I don't do
that but I was my [__] together I'm
smart enough to do that I do that too I
do do that too oh there's a kick chat oh
my God happy Destiny demise day all
right I'm going to try to watch both
chats usually I just uh watch MRG
girl.tv chat but you know I'm going to
try to accomodate everybody today
Destiny crime Marathon maybe that's
right apparently he called Gucci a PTO
who's Gucci I don't know who that is
right where are the callers what's going
on hello it's also I'm pausing a lot
okay I do want to listen to him talk
it's really interesting he does callers
he uh you get like a key and you're able
to enter and like I don't know I don't
know how to describe it but when I did
my Callin it was very very interesting
it wasn't like any other Callin I've
done before all right interesting stuff
happening in the Mr girl Discord hey can
you hear me yes how are you doing
tonight I'm okay uh little
motion um I mean it's weird because
you're learning about I mean yeah
obviously it feels good to be Vindicated
on some level but it feels bad to hear
about people having their autonomy
violated so that's exactly what I was
going to ask because I I don't know if
you changed the stream title I think you
referenced that at the beginning but no
I didn't I didn't change it well I'm
assuming and from what you've been
saying that it's somewhat tongue and
cheek but I mean it does really seem
like you have been Vindicated has he
been Vindicated I still think the way he
went about things I I still have to do
more research on it cuz it's a lot it's
going through like 3ish years of lore
and I have to do it like in Timeline
order I'm trying to figure [__] out
still but is he completely Vindicated I
like Mr girl I enjoy his content from
what I've seen of it
um but I think he he did go about things
a little not the best right I think his
objective has been Vindicated uh maybe I
don't know I don't know if he's been
Vindicated necessarily I guess I
mean I think that that's a reasonable
feeling to have I don't think it has to
be superseded by or maybe it should be
maybe it should you know come second to
a feeling of guilt but I think that
could be a pretty profound feeling that
you have of being Vindicated well
Vindication is just in the eye of the
beholder right so like it's not like
everybody has left the
uh the
C what would be the response that would
be sufficient in your mind here's what
helps preserve the
cult um let's say you start in the
middle just in this diagram the middle
is you're totally loyal and then you as
you move outward you're being more and
more critical and then you either get
ejected or leave that seems to be the
path that most people leave Destin's
Community right or you could make that
diagram okay the thing is as you're
ejected uh you get smeared as a
disgusting undesirable crazy
narcissistic rapist whatever what my
curiosity I want to explain something to
you is Grace Thorp in the chat I think
Grace Thorp is in the live Rumble chat
right now unless that's just not her I'm
pretty sure that's Grace Thorp in the
chat Jesus will you just listen for a
second yeah absolutely okay so um this
creates this split where all the people
who think as you're on your way out
let's say I'm right uh at the Event
Horizon I'm right I'm right escape
velocity I'm about to hit escape
velocity so I'm still part of the cult
but I'm about to leave right everyone in
the cult uh thinks I'm okay they think
that I'm you know a smart cool non-
rapist whatever everybody outside thinks
I'm kind of weird at best and then I
think all the people who've been ejected
before me because I've learned about
them through Destiny I think they're all
disgusting awful people and they all
think each other are disgusting awful
people then I make my want his
headphones what are those are these not
the generic like uh like like the $900
headphones uh I'm not sure uh they're
easy to find I think these are the
whatever like they're the high-end like
XLR cable ones I think I'm almost
certain criticism Destiny is abuser he's
manipulative uh sexual SST whatever sis
I think they the cult flips and now in
the cult's eyes I'm a I'm a narcissist
malignant narcissist rapist and then to
everybody outside they're still looking
at me through the lens of Destiny so
they still think I'm a pedophile rapist
now and then so where's the Vindication
the Vindication is only the next Group
after uh maybe they're not you know what
maybe he was right about Destiny but
even though I know about him from all my
opinions about him are still formed by
this person I now believe is a liar he's
still a pedophile narcisstic wife being
rapist so it's uh indication is a strong
word and but then and as Casey Tron just
pointed out on or Terry just quote
tweeted Casey Tron on Twitter point this
out this happens to everybody everybody
is like oh yeah you know what Destiny is
a liar but all those people he told me
about are awful horrible crazy monsters
yeah I'm not sure that I I don't really
I wouldn't say that I'm a part of his
community um I don't really have a
presence in I don't have any presence I
don't have an account on DG or anything
along those lines um what there may be a
point of disagreement between you and I
I think it's insane that retroactively
Destiny thought he was a rapist because
he decided to go back and write the Dr
yeah I think if I'm remembering correct
ly and this was kind of telephone to me
so I could be entirely wrong I'm pretty
sure how he went about it is Destiny saw
what Mr girl was doing and he's like
yeah I used to think that Mr girl
understood consent and autonomy and
stuff but now that he's doing this I
don't think he understands autonomy so I
don't think he would be a rapist if he
understood consent at the level that I
thought he did but now I don't think he
does so I don't think he he understands
consent and autonomy which makes the
encounters that he's had to me
in his mind more like rape right I think
I think I think I think I think I think
I don't know well you have to have seen
um his response the basic um I think it
was obviously um pretty unsophisticated
red definitely milici the main issue
that I don't think anybody's really
accusing him I maybe some people are
maliciously you know um doing something
with the antenna pixie you know um you
know the porographic materials being
leaked but what he what he really is
being accused of he completely sesu and
I think that I mean there were thousands
of comments on that Reddit thread and I
I I looked through quite a few I didn't
of course I didn't look through even
maybe a fraction of the overall
thousands of comments but every single
comment that I saw um was negative
towards Destiny some of them were
extremely negative and I think that
Destiny has a really um he's really
great at obious dating do you think rape
is malicious yeah absolutely that that
would be something that yes I do well no
that that that was going to be something
that I was you get you get I do want to
get into it okay why is why is R
malicious well I understand what you're
trying to do and I'm agreeing with you I
think that what you just answer I'm
going to if you would allow me um I
think what Destiny did wait that's not
answer to my question I want you to
answer my
question why is rape malicious I would
say that rape is malicious in the same
way that leaking somebody's private you
know pornographic material is malicious
and is rape malicious rape is more
selfish than malicious I would say right
malice what does malice mean the
intention or desire to be evil uh what I
I think it's Mal malicious some people
use rape to control yeah I think it um
it would have to depend Alish okay come
on dude Jesus Christ malicious malicious
uh I think it depends right I think
you'd have to go Case by case I think it
could be malicious I think it could be
selfish I think it could be a power play
uh and I think it could be all three at
once isn't the whole thing of rape you
get off on taking power from another
person you can but I don't think that's
the rule I think there's it's the same
reason like not all child molesters are
pedophiles right some people enjoy the
power not everybody gets off solely to
the fact that it's a kid right there's
other reasons you could enjoy that thing
or do that thing I don't think saying
that rape sometimes rape isn't malicious
and sometimes it's entirely selfish
doesn't take away from the fact that
someone was raped I think rape is
obviously bad um but I think it doesn't
have to be malicious I think more often
than not it would be malicious but I
don't think it has to be I think there
are other reasons why someone could
could rape why is rape without comparing
to something else why is rap why am I
not allowed to compare the two because
it is a cult think way to avoid directly
answering a question about a specific
thing I disagree okay what is your
evaluation of this thing independent of
everything well if I was if I were
compare to stealing a banana out of the
back of someone's backpack then I like
you don't need to do that why is rap
malicious I think it's malicious because
you're exploiting somebody in many cases
the fact that it's it's almost and maybe
it is because I'm a cultist um but I'm
finding it impossible not to relate it
back to the specific thing with pixie's
information you don't have imagine
imagine a nun came up to you on the
street and said why is rap malicious and
you say you say well pixie and Cherry
and like the thing is that with the
questin in August of 2022 the law hadn't
even been passed yet so you got
AR why is rape malicious to the old lady
none who doesn't know who Destiny is um
I think it's I want to answer that
because I think that's an interesting
question why is rape
malicious um the intention to do evil or
ill will or desire to do evil so if you
have a desire to rape and you go through
with it I think rape is probably evil I
think rape is one of the worst things
you can do so I would definitely label
rape as evil right so if you have a
desire to rape and then you go through
with that and you do the action of rape
I think that makes it malicious right
guys rape is bad I listen all right
listen okay it is it's Evil all right I
think it would be malicious because I
think the desire the desire itself I
don't think is malicious but the desire
alongside with the actually going
through with it is evil and you have a
desire to do evil which would be
malicious maybe right is that a good
reasoning is that a good reasoning
you're taking away someone's autonomy uh
yeah I yeah I don't think anybody's
arguing against that how is the desire
not malicious I think the desire well
cuz if you're just fantasizing about
raping someone I don't think that really
matters to me it's the desire alongside
actually going through with it I think
okay YouTube censored you rape is wrong
and bad thank you Jimbo slice for the $5
thank you very much
appreciative I appreciate it all right I
appreciate it thank you I do appreciate
it um I don't the desire in it of itself
I don't think is bad but it's the desire
like it the premeditative desire I hope
I said that word right and then they
going through with it maybe I think I
think okay I've never actually thought
about why rape would be malicious
because I've never heard someone
describe it as malicious but I hear
malicious and I hear rape is malicious
and I agree with that so it's
interesting to try and uh it's
interesting to try and Define why it is
the way I think it is let's hear what
this guy has to say though I think it's
malicious because people really value as
they should their sexuality and having
somebody take something from you in
terms of you know you're ay what you
want in your life and your sexuality is
a something that causes extreme harm to
somebody and in order for a person to
rape a person there has to be an immense
disregard for that person's wellbeing
okay so apathy and harm sure yeah okay
and when you say leaking the news wasn't
malicious it sounds like you're also
referring to my claim that he that it
actually may be sadistic he may enjoy
the the danger and the humiliation
that's the case I think you're right
what I would say and wait you think I'm
right that he enjoys the danger and
humiliation absolutely yeah okay so okay
so you view it as entirely malicious in
every possible way we could Define it
well so I think if you had allowed me I
would have gone to this point um and I
misspoke but the the distinction that I
would make would would be would you
admit that um destiny just leaking if he
just went on Twitter and said here are
here is um a Google Docs of a variety of
different people that um I have
pornographic materials that they don't
want me to tweet out and he did that
would that be more or less malicious
than know why we I don't think imagine
you had you're the one who's confronting
me on the issue that's imagine you had
your imagine imagine you had your
consent violated by this absolute piece
of [__] and you're watching a stream
about it and then they're like well how
okay so what if your consent been
violated this way what have been viol
this way what if what if your rapist had
done this instead of this would you
which which thing would be worse what if
he did this while he did this and then
did this and then said this about it I
don't want to get into I'm okay I'm okay
with entertaining thought experiment I'm
okay with entertaining thought
experiments but the problem with the
endless comparisons to things that did
or did not happen is that it gets away
from Clear concise condemnation of a
sexual predator okay how about this I
believe wholeheartedly that Destiny is a
sexual abuser I believe he's a predator
I would go so far as to say and I'm sure
many other people would that this the
the case of what what he did to pixie
what he did to Molina what he did to
Cherry are in my intuition tells me that
there's no almost no possible way that
these are isolated instances I want you
to think about the sentence that you
just said because you I was like we got
to be clear and concise you're like okay
I clear and concise I could do that and
then you just did what you just did take
the strength of the words you're using
on a scale of 1 to 10 so maybe like a
eight and then for every comma in your
sentence subtract one so I think we're
at about one or two and that is the
strength of your condemnation I I don't
I don't see how me expounding on why I
think he's a sexual predator takes away
from the point that I'm making because
the audience can't even follow what
you're saying it sounds like you can't
even follow what you're saying it's not
about being no it's not it's not about
being stupid it's about you speaking
like Destiny and using the rhetorical
tools that he uses without even knowing
you're using them even inside your own
head where Destiny is a sexual predator
and then there's just silence and then
wow that hits pretty different from
Destiny I think what you say I think
Destiny a sexually abusive and a
predator and I think sexual abuser then
you brought up Molina and then there was
a bunch of different that I don't
remember and then it ended with and I
think maybe there's even then it went
into postulating about the possibility
of more victims and then by the time
youve gotten that I'm like what was
weren't you making a condemnation now
we're just talking there's this stud is
so annoying do you mean the caller or do
you mean Mr girl at all if somebody came
up to you and accused somebody you know
personally and said oh this person's a
rapist and then you said why and then
they start telling you why you would
just yourown off it would start to
become uninteresting or you wouldn't be
able to follow because the condemnation
isn't succinct
enough what are you asking me how is I
don't understand I'm saying that it's
too it's look if you gave a sharp even a
5minute monologue that's like a a five
paragraph essay explaining why Destiny
is a sexual predator I wouldn't have
this reaction it's the spiraling
endlessly tangential speculative thought
experiment nature of how you're speaking
that St one in the conversation but it's
just the way I'm trying to articulate a
belief I have that it's obvious that
this guy is a bad guy honestly I think
me and I I admittedly I'm disappointed
in the way that this conversation is
going I'm sure you are as well I'm
criticizing how you're articulating that
and that is to say you aren't you're
saying it but also in a way that doesn't
say it yeah I'm at a loss for words I'm
not quite sure what to say I think um
how can you be at a loss for words when
you were speaking so much you seem to be
overwhelmed by words maybe that's the
case maybe it's nerves or something else
but I I don't I don't think it's nerves
everyone Destiny speaks this way and
thinks this way and all of us all of his
followers do too I don't think it's what
is it specifically I'm saying that's
Destiny like it's the structure of what
you're saying not the words can you be
more specific endlessly redirecting
answering questions with questions yeah
I feel I feel like you're just
completely disra or derailing this I
don't I don't like what you just did you
ask me a question you said can be more
specific I start BR question you just
asked me how that back can you say
specifically as in provide an example of
something I said that you think is
similar to the way that Destiny thinks I
just repeated what you said back to you
and explained how it was similar you
want me to do it more sure okay the way
you just said sure is the way Destiny
thinks it's sarcastic condescending I'm
not being sarcastic I want you to
provide more examples I'm not being I'm
giving you an example the way you just
asked me for an example the way you just
said sure is sarcastic and condescending
it's double speak it's meant to tell the
audience I'm being super charitable and
I'm going to listen to the stupid
[__] [__] say something that's so
[__] that I shouldn't even have to
sit here and listen to it I'm not even
going to have to come up with a response
it's poisoning the well and it's passive
aggressive [__] going so poorly I
just want to hear what you have to say
and and bro you just asked me twice to
answer this question and I'm telling you
the answer and you're like not listening
to it I'm listening you said that me
saying sure is condescending and
sarcastic I don't think that if that's
the way Eng with that what I'm
absolutely yes I'm saying I'm I'm sorry
that you feel that I was are you what
are you interr me can I can I get
through the sentence the sentence where
you're going to sarcastically apologize
yes please okay I'm not sorry that you
view it as being condescending
and sarcastic I do that you find it
sarcas and when I'm asking you for a
specific example I'm not doing it
intentionally you saying sure
sarcastically is the example I'm giving
you do you understand that yes and I'm
trying to engage with it by saying I
disagree that I said it I don't know how
I can't hear I've got a new example I'm
trying to engage with it that's that
sentence what does that mean either
engage with it or don't but saying the
the sentence I'm trying to engage with
it itself isn't trying to engage with it
it's like if you say to somebody I
always lie that can't logically Mak
sense the sentence contradicts itself
it's double
speak engage with what you're saying
that's it's inherently wrong the
sentence yeah Parx it's paradoxical and
it tells the audience that you're doing
one thing while you're actually doing
another and I believe that you actually
believe this I don't think that you're
like being sneaky or something I'm
saying that that I think there's a a big
problem with the way that he's taught
people to think and
speak yeah I don't know I I I I I watch
Destiny's content he is a no me like way
the the primary you know I I don't even
know how to articulate it but it's it's
not like I'm watching 9 hours a day of
Destiny and contribut 90% of my diet of
media I mean it's interesting that
despite him being such a Mr girl
masterfully derails I can't watch this
guy my God how is this a derail this is
his live stream [__] what do you
mean what what part of it he would have
an overwhelming control over the way I
speak and the way that I interact with
others maybe I'm projecting I think you
are okay well that's just my opinion and
I think that if yeah if I wanted to
psych psycho analyze where you're coming
from I think the fact that I said that I
um you know whether I'm part of
Destiny's Community or whatever it is I
think that was me unintentionally
muddying the waters where you kind of
get to the point where you don't really
want to hear what I have to say or what
do you have to say what would you like
to talk about I don't know the only
thing I really want I mean and now I
almost don't even want to say it but the
main reason he doesn't know dude oh my
God bro the most annoying thing when
someone calls into a [__] stream and
they don't even have something they want
to say Jesus Christ [__] don't even
call in then don't even call in then if
you don't have anything you want to talk
about or say don't even call in then
Jesus Christ oh my God I wanted to call
in was because uh okay perfect um J
that's actually a double hedge I I don't
even want to say it and the main reason
I wanted to call in so you're not about
to say what you're about to say what
you're about to say is no no no no no
you've already framed it as what you're
about to say isn't actually what you're
saying you're just explaining what you
wanted to say when you called in you see
how that Hedges no well what I would say
is if I were if I were going to say
something right now the thing that I
would be about to say if I were going to
say it would be why don't you just I'll
say speak just yeah just the floor is
yours I'm not I don't have a show like
this this isn't something I'm used to
doing but okay perfect um Jess or I
think it's j stalker
okay he had he he um was talking about
Cherry I think it was last night and he
was saying that he wanted people to DM
her you know affirmations because she
thinks that she's in a situation where
there's a lot of people that are just
that they think she's a liar that they
don't believe what she's saying reverse
harassment I'm saying it's
anti-harassment that'd be a better way
no that's what I was and me calling in
was a similar thing I wanted to um voice
my support for what you were doing and
say that I think you have been
Vindicated in many ways and I think a
lot of people a lot of people in dy's
community feel similarly I'm not sure
what you read on the totality of how
many people are against him in this and
it may not matter it may be the case
that if there's a group of people who
are you know would denounce Desy for
what he did but would say something
along the lines of he's just growing or
you know this isn't going to stop me
from engaging with his content I don't
know what sufficient for you I'm just
trying I was just trying to voice my
support that's it I mean I had a yeah
absolutely um and I'm not saying that
sarcastically but um I had a couple of
points that maybe are you talking can
can you hear me yeah I'm talking I was
whispering oh okay gotcha I have like a
kind of shitty headphones so regardless
um I don't know a couple of points of
contention that would be the main thing
is but I was honestly kind of surprised
because I do buy into the cult thing
where you know it's whole Donald Trump
that he said he could go out onto Fifth
afteron and shoot somebody and You'
still have community that is absolutely
the case for Destiny I think there is
not to some Len I think I think we got
go to the next caller soon you can you
can we slow down can we speed up by
slowing down we just slow down ADHD yeah
just take a second take a second and
then is you said so I appreciate you
congratulating me on my total and
complete Vindication to qu Trum you
should try to make him real plushy with
makeship dude my my viewers Peak at like
150 I don't think I'm going to get like
enough purchases for a m plushy okay I
don't listen I don't foresee AAL plushy
in the near future okay why socks though
where hoodies too expensive I just don't
have a hoodie design I'll do hoodies
eventually I don't know when though and
I appreciate the the well wishes you
said you had a point of contention is
there something you want to content
about I don't even know if it would be a
contention um that that that was the
main point as I wanted to convey that in
my point of view that there is substan
I'm getting to it I was just about I
don't want you get I don't want you to
I'm getting to it again I'm getting to
it doesn't really make sense you either
are at it or you're not or I'm going to
the store I don't want you to go there I
want to be there because we got to end
this right now okay yeah my only point
was to say I think a large amount of his
community is leaving and that they
believe that what he did was horrendous
and disqualifying which I would tend to
agree with okay well I agree with that
too okay that's good we're on the same
page then okay well okay I'm going to go
to the next caller thank you for calling
Mr realine I appreciate it no problem
byebye right that guy sucked I not a fan
of that guy not a fan of that guy put a
morow socks if V1 design onto a tie I'd
wear that to a funeral I don't know if I
can do that that sounds awesome okay
thank you for the five five Australian
it seems all right um Everybody buckle
your meta conversation seat belts okay I
should have warned you you know but I
want you to I want you to approach meta
comments with an open mind because meta
comments prevent people from being
manipulative even if they don't know
they being manipulative or evasive or
from pulling a lot of little tricks that
you don't you wouldn't notice unless you
slow things down and I think the speed
with which Destiny speaks uh the speed
with which you're expected to speak when
speaking in his community or his orbit
rutes to um replacing the thoughts of
the viewer or preventing critical
thought in the viewer preventing
critical thought in the orbiters and it
all serves to uh help him have narrative
control so there are times where I'm
going to just say we got to slow down
and I and squeaky toy plush so it
doubles for humans or pets wow thanks
I'm of course IM was sort of as just
like a guy who likes having meta
conversation for no reason because I'm
crazy I want you to rethink this
assessment and I want you to to look how
if you make a condemnation of Predator
sexual predatory behavor sexually predat
Behavior but you do it in a way that is
like jumping around and going from to
thing to thing you can actually
seriously soften what you're saying um
in a way that I think benefits abusers
in this case Destiny okay hello there
hey you had your camera on but then you
turned it off oh it's back yeah oh you
just didn't want me awkwardly watching
you while I speak to the chat um no
that's okay no no that's not that's not
why I turned it off okay the no is
saying you're wrong oh I know okay I was
pretending to think you were admitting
to it it is weird it's
Fresh Light please thank you puddle
sucker uh no promises no promises
especially after everything I just said
uh it's a bizarre thing to do but that's
what I did how you uh how you been um
very emotionally disregulated I would
say is the word why have you been
emotionally
disregulated uh cuz it's just like all
this [__] that I kind of had to push
down is all back up Suddenly black black
Mr girl fan interesting okay here we go
or maybe not push down but kind of try
to leave behind and move on and move on
to other projects and I'm suddenly I
feel uh thrust back into it all of a
sudden and it's a lot to deal with and
um watching this happened to pixie Jerry
is tough that's Benny o oh is it Benny
okay Benny is that [__] I was watching
jstock and I'm pretty sure Benny was uh
saying some like really dumb [__] like
some really [__] [__] and I was like
why is this guy on the stream I think
queman was there I don't know I had a
really bad first impression of Benny
right I like an insanely bad he calls
into jto he can't help it okay okay I
mean they're going a lot more support
than you did the last time right yeah
but they also were violated in a way
that I was not so true true this um
still pretty hard to watch oh this is a
this is a victory live stream right I
don't know if that's really in my nature
so I I don't it's going to be more like
a victory
crawl oh okay well it is in my nature I
want to start off by saying block
counter point points that stupid [__]
[__] Dan that [__] um [__] Destiny
[__] the fans really really [__] the
fans I'm tired of these stupid ass fans
you know the worst part about it is the
worst part about it is sh right they're
so brainwashed oh yeah what was bad what
do you want me to say that's not enough
it's not enough you knew you knew for
the past month and a half what happened
but before that you should have known
when Mr girl came out with this article
and now you're starting to pretend again
more pretending like releasing of these
uh I don't think you could plausibly get
that Destiny was is doing like revenge
porn and spreading like like sex tapes
uncons with the Mr girl article I don't
think you could predict that but I get
the general I get the general sentiment
okay just a hey man everybody makes
mistakes no it wasn't mistake he's a
sick [__] he's a liar he's a hypocrite
he's a piece of [__] and you've known
that or at least you should have it's so
obvious all the time dur red P AR I like
young [__] the biggest problem with
me and Molina's uh relationship is she's
too young for me right right right at 30
years old I have a sister who's 19 the
idea the idea that somebody who's 30 I'm
not even 30 yet the idea that somebody
who's 30 who claims to hate young
[__] is going to show a sexually
inexperienced um shelter he's like
crying while this black guy's like
speaking his
[Music]
[__] what what kind of creepy nasty
bastard is just a liar he just lies to
you blatantly you still want to make it
seem like it was a mistake it was a
mistake this is what he does [__] I
never got to say this at least not as
many times as I wanted to remember
during the the lucky Arc this to all the
fans I've been here for a long time I've
been Desy fan since 2016 2017 remember
during the lucky Arc people were
starting to say m oh maybe he doesn't
understand
consent it was prophetic it was it was
so it was she see to the Future like
That's So Raven what is happening she
said hey if if you think I do any weird
[__] [__] cuz that's the way he talks
weird [__] [__] uh you know I'm an open
book my whole life is on the internet
you can ask anybody you want you can
talk to anybody you want everybody knows
that uh and then the second Mr girl
starts an investigation he gets nuked
from orbit that didn't rain is strange
to you no it doesn't matter as long as
he protected as long as the cult is
protected you people make me sick to my
[__] stomach that piece of [__] danam
he goes on anything else and he says Oh
Mr girl abuses his wife out of one side
of his mouth and on the other side of
his mouth he's saying well used to call
me and cry telling me all these horrible
things about Destiny maybe I should
leave and I said well if you feel like
you're in abusive relationship maybe you
should leave what a stupid [__]
[__] what a dumb [__] [__]
that's the best thing about Dan is that
he's so [__] dumb everything he tries
to do he sabotages he's sabotaging his
friend's defense he's [__] disgusting
and his own words pedophile friends
defense oh if you're 19 you're basically
15 to me his his own by his own
definition he sabes his own [__]
pedophile friend defense he destroys his
[__] uh uh Crusade against Dan
whatever the [__] guy from twitch
whatever the [__] that guy's name is
what a [__] [__] Counterpoint dick
sucker of the Year dick sucker of the
century I hate you all and ukraini [__]
you too [__] yes [__]
ukana yes think it's a cult oh the D
yeah I've been convinced that it's a
cult since I started to get the incling
that it was a cult it was sometime
during the red pill Arc he had a debate
with this guy called angry man and uh he
said something
R of are homophobic he treat not with
which is like none because he doesn't
have any blackmail friends um as if like
they're automatically without any
question homophobic and so he was
talking to the angry man guy and the
angry man guy made fun of his hair and
he was like oh I wish it was [__]
2011 the jokes that I could make I was
like what what you going to call N word
cuz he made F of your blue hair and then
um I made a post in his subred and
people were like AR they were they they
were vociferously arguing with me they
could not handle the idea that Desy
might be a little bit racist so that's
when I started to get to enging and then
once you know I think once you started
to like get into seriously like heated
debates with Destiny I started to see
the CTS the cultish brainwashing more
more more and more clearly so I do think
it's a
yeah you like the Fest stuff um what say
again what was the question the Fest
stuff what about
it yeah you said heated debates yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was around that time
but it wasn't really that it was like
after that because after all the F stuff
the air had like shifted and like the
community started to dislike revisionist
history is crazy okay gringle oh gringle
oh my God what do you do do you post
with very little to no push back people
just believe all the things that he said
about you if it's a cult do you think
these people are brainwashed you're
speaking about them like they're
knowingly you're calling them pieces of
[__] you're speaking about them so I I I
do believe that Destiny is has no uh
Illusions about what he is doing and who
he is but at then end comes across to me
like a True Believer like he I agree he
is sabotaging Destiny in a way but it
seems like he can't stop himself like he
feels deeply emotionally driven
he fell asleep I think he fell asleep on
J Stock's stream the other night just to
try to be there to prevent me from
talking about Destiny and I think in a
way he's trying to prevent himself from
thinking about Destiny by doing that
it's like he's trying to shut down
dissenting voices not for any practical
manipulative intellectually sound reason
it can't be part of like a scheme or a
plan because it doesn't make sense
doesn't help Destiny there's no way
des's watching that it's like glad Dan's
doing that doesn't that make it seem
like he is brainwashed like truly yeah
is a little bit different um I think you
can maybe make that argument for like
counter points Maybe Ukrainian Anna but
I think I actually think that Dan is
like a malevolent person I think for a
while now I felt like Dan is like a um I
agree Dan is a malevolent person
H
Mal having a wish to do evil to others
Dan malevolent um has Dan really done
anything evil yep he's Jewish okay come
on he sticks by bullying Anam uh well I
don't I obviously don't like that I
don't know if that's that's him trying
to be malevolent though right
he tried to kill twitch but it it it
seems like he had like a a decent moral
reason as to why if he's malevolent I
don't think it's it's self-aware I don't
think it's self-aware if he is okay
that's what I'll say that's my take
official Mor take okay extremely
self-centered to the point where it's
like in a way he's also he's also
showboating for Destiny by talking about
how self-centered he is um isn't that
isn't he just showing you know pledging
his fty to the cult isn't that what
you're supposed to do bra about how how
self-centered you are I think he's I
think he's pledging his fty but I think
it's it's in a calculated way I don't
think that like he's doing it because he
thinks it's the right thing to do I
think he's doing it because um anything
else money is is probably pretty good
okay and maybe we disagree about Dan you
think that Connor and Anna are True
Believers um I want I want to try to Mr
girl talking to Darius like live um
between opportunists True Believers or
mix because I I I do think it's a little
unfair BR gamma is debating Sammy on
slurs hey it gets hello we're debating
hate symbolism what's up continue go
okay so um Sammy restate your position
please I cannot he's live I I don't even
remember your position to be honest it's
a problem but why is it a bad thing that
I'm live I'm not a person put somebody
on the spot you're not it doesn't matter
you're you're an individual you're
having a discussion it's entertaining
yeah it's a discussion pulled out of
[__] thin air yeah we just like I
just I just came up
great so so really really the
conversation is about like hate
symbolism yeah it's like if it's not
funny we agree that if it's a joke it's
probably excusable but it's like I think
if the joke's not funny GMA is like you
should just assume it's not serious and
my whole point is
like I I said that generally what's your
favorite okay I I said that like
generally speaking if somebody is like
posting what do you mean what's wrong
with saying your favorite what what I
don't have a favorite Slayer thank you
though
to for SL I've said it to Sammy and dmms
three times did you call her the nword
yeah really can we see that can we see
screenshots of that no can we get can we
get eyes on this no why
not uh she's black and I don't want to
get I don't want to get in trouble not
good this is not a good look M this is
not a good look you should really be
transparent as possible you should be
honest with your audience you should
know what you're calling people behind
the scenes you supported the big leowski
you vouch for the big leowski his rise
is on you [__] all right
to call someone who's literally
brainwashed sh and I'm not saying we're
saying cult we mean cult like I don't
think either of us are using the term as
an insult or a smear or an exaggeration
right it's not hyperbole it's a literal
cult yeah or are you saying it's cult
like literal cult literal cult um it's
it's it's close it's it's not like you
know the Manson family but it's okay so
if you don't believe it's literally a
cult then I see why I'm going to mun on
some chicken right now on these people
all right implies if any of you even
care I guess I think there's been a
level of deception narrative control and
confusion
that while I everybody has ageny and is
respons for their own decisions they're
operating blind kind of and they don't
think they truly don't understand what
they're doing and so they can be held
accountable and they should wake the
[__] up but I think acting as though
they're totally sober and aware of what
they're doing is a little unfair I
understand the point that you're making
my only issue is like no he's talk
Ukrainian Anna not yeah yeah yeah not
not an War um you can literally like you
can you can listen to you can listen to
the people speak like not only can you
listen to the people speak like when
you're not when you're not sure you can
just refrain from having an opinion like
Britney Simon I never really had an
opinion on her the only thing about
Britney Simon that I felt was I didn't
like that she said [__] you because I'm
a fan of you but outside of that like I
never really had a very strong opinion
on Britney Simon because I don't watch
her content I don't know anything about
her so when Desy said [__] Britney Simon
I didn't go along like yeah she was a
crazy [__] the whole time and the like
and so if you do that I think that like
you're willingly I kind of want to
rewatch The Britney Simon video that she
made on Destiny and Lauren Southern with
with my current lens because I thought
she was like a skitso insane [__] but
going like after this I might go back
and watch it which really quick like two
exent maybe because I'm I'm curious if
I'm like Britney Simon pilled now all
right maybe she's based maybe I'm maybe
I join her what what does she call her
fan basees like kittens maybe I'm a
Britney Simon kitten okay maybe you
could be more skeptical especially in a
community full of atheist it's like I'm
I'm I'm the Catholic who's looking at
the ethot and being like you'll just buy
you'll just believe anything it's like
you could be more skeptical and you just
choose not to because you just you just
love this guy so much but that's to me
that's willfully blind and so if they're
being willfully blind um you know there
there's a certain amount like obvious I
should probably have more um vitory all
for like you know Destiny or you know
his orbiters than like the fans but
there's still something for them too
like I don't I don't look at Trump
supporters and go well Trump just
deceives you so it's not [__] you no
it's [__] you too but like yeah it's
[__] you think there's a civic duty to
not be deceived by demagog yeah I do I
do I think I think you in particular put
too much responsibility on platforms and
um the leaders of movements or cult or
whatever and not have enough
responsibility on the people who are
involved or inside of the cult that's
fair it's a cult you can keep in your
pocket
d That's What wannab be sad boy just
said in chat I don't really know what
that means I'll the honest truth a cult
you can keep in your pocket I think he's
saying that when you think of a cult as
being unlike you know a reservation
somewhere a compound compound out in the
desert with topless drug addict girls
and Marilyn mans not Marilyn Manson
Charles Manson telling you to kill and
so then when you see people just you
know coming home from their long day at
work or at at work you know with their
their earbuds and listening to Destiny
it doesn't it doesn't seem like it's a
cult I think he's saying it's a portable
cult it has all the the trappings and
all the bad parts of a cult without the
phys part I feel that I feel that over
identify with the leader give him as
much of your money as you possibly can
it's like a cult without free food
pretty shitty cult yeah well I mean you
get to feel more superiority over you
know Destiny's enemies at the very least
yeah um what about to say oh um yeah all
the people who I guess have a problem
with a uh with a quote unquote Victory
live stream or with people you know I
won't say you know taking the attention
off of Pixie and Cherry but like drawing
attention to other things like again I
want to reiterate it's really important
that you understand this is not oopsy he
didn't make a mistake this is what he's
like he's obviously a sick narcissistic
sociopathic whatever it is you want to
say of I do agree I think um I going
forward really want to watch the
rhetoric I use around Destiny because I
feel like unintentionally or maybe
subconsciously I have downplayed it
maybe to myself and maybe to people that
I talk to and maybe to people watching
my streams right Destiny knew what he
was doing was
bad he knew and he still did it anyways
and Destiny didn't spread like revenge
porn like don't use a blanket term like
that right Destiny didn't spread some
girls nudes don't use like a a blanket
term like that Destiny spread a graphic
sex tape between an at the time
19-year-old and him being in his like
early 30s or late 20s I think early 30s
he spread a graphic sex tape that was
recorded with the consent of an at the
time virgin who was very nervous about
sex who trusted
Destiny and he took that he recorded it
and he spread it around and I I think
personally I'm not going to like moral F
over it too hard if someone says he
spread revenge porn or he spread nudes
whatever like I'll correct them but I'm
not you know whatever right gringle in
the server debate time I don't know what
I would debate gringle on I forgot why I
was upset with him do we have any solid
proof yet that d man was recorded that D
Man recorded without consent he recorded
it with consent then spread it uncons
and then Cherry is alleging that she was
recorded uncons and then some other
leaked DMS heavily insinuate uh that he
recorded some grinder hookups UNC
consensually he said not to take Mr girl
serious no that was someone else I
banned him from chat and he didn't join
the VC so I believe Cherry I believe her
even more now that she's talked to J
stck and J stock vouched for her I
believe Cherry but I I think a lot of
people's language language around this
really does uh downplay what happened I
think the amount of trust that was
violated in this situation is uh is is
mindboggling and I don't think a lot of
people use the correct language to
convey them I don't even think I'm using
the correct language I'm trying to get
there I'm trying to find the correct
words to say right but ultimately um the
amount of consent and privacy and trust
that was violated of a young woman is uh
is mindboggling it is it is disgusting
to me
look at topic suggestions okay
what I I think people when they shop for
news they look for stuff that makes them
feel good but that's their main
criticism of the mainstream media right
that they just feed slop don't you think
you have people in your audience that
probably go to you for that content slot
yeah probably most of them that's why
there's like a joke where like if a
certain video is coming out and people
are um watching in my stream and they
all have like an opinion they think I
have or whatever and then I watch the
full video and then I give a take but
it's the opposite they spam that like
the driving guy emote because they're
all doing like a 180 because like oh
[__] so yeah there are people that watch
me that copy my opinion and should be
doing more critical thinking but I
encourage people to think for themselves
and to evaluate their stuff and I try to
I think my audience is pretty good at
being critical of me like for as much as
people say I ban everybody that
disagrees something think there's a
healthy amount of there's a decent
amount of hate on your
sub serous stuff person like he almost
never admits when he's wrong you know
maybe maybe if you prove him to wrong on
something like 3 years down the line be
like Oh I'm try to change my mind on
this but never in the moment will he
ever or even the next stream or the
stream after that um within the month be
like yeah I was wrong about this it
almost never happens um he uh uh
obviously he's inconsiderate doesn't
care about other people's feelings
somebody who claims to understand
consent wouldn't just send around
pictures and videos of other people
record them from his pocket without them
knowing it's insane and so the idea that
people are like not only is it insane
we've been telling you this the entire
time for somebody to be like oh you just
want to make it about yourself no no we
want to make it about him as well as the
victim so that you understand that it's
not accident this is what he
does also really briefly just to get out
my thoughts I think Connor Connor
counter points Conor points CUNY points
CP points
um I think he downplays what Destiny did
like an insane amount by just like
calling him
[__] like I I feel like and I don't
exactly know how to back this up and it
may be is a little silly for me to just
like say my feelings without having
something to like seriously back it up
whatever whatever okay I
think calling him [__] takes away
like an insane amount of of agency on
Destiny's
end has Cherry ever lied before if she
hasn't then yeah maybe I would believe
it a bit more um I don't think I don't
no I don't think so um but as far as I
know she sent a part of the recording to
someone to vouch and say that it's real
and she's placing criminal charges on
Destiny for doing this and Destiny's a
[__]
millionaire so I don't I don't see any
reason why Cherry would lie about
this I I see absolutely no reason yeah I
believe J stock heard it that's yeah
that's what I'm referencing I don't see
any reason why she would
lie I believe her wholeheartedly
believe
her uh I trust her I don't think she's
lying I don't think this is something
she would lie
about uh yeah yeah but I do think Connor
is uh is indeed severely downplaying uh
Destiny's actions by calling him things
like [__] I do think that I also
believe MK I do believe MK I do believe
MC
I think Connor is sweeping by saying
he's [__] because I feel like that
removes some sort of agency
right I don't
know I don't know I don't know maybe I'm
too emotional all right maybe I'm woman
coded maybe I was written by a car maybe
I was written by a
woman all right let's keep going yeah I
feel um
like it's important to try to steer The
Narrative towards what I believe is the
truth and away from what you know people
are saying in chat sarcastically all he
did was goon chill out guys like the
problem is that he's too he's too sexual
not that he's too sociopathic
yeah like there are plenty of people who
are goers they don't like just violate
people's consent especially when they
claim to know to understand consent so
well especially like when he wrote a
whole Manifesto on a person you know
saying that he's a bad person because he
was sending around people's news without
their consent especially like when his
wife told him previously not to send her
news around without it's just I can't I
can't believe it I can't believe that
Conor would go on that stream and say
those things it just doesn't it's so
crazy it's so crazy hey Connor would he
be a what make him a predator maybe he
did it like 12 times he's done it at
least six how do you feel now what do
you think you should go to jail you lost
your mind but again yeah it's the True
Believer thing oh yeah that's fair
that's fair that's
fair think it doesn't make look good it
doesn't make Desy look good I I think I
think he it just feels like he has to
say that I doesn't make sense to me
otherwise no I agree I 1,000% I think
Connor's
sweeping I think uh I might watch the
the
quean call with lav and
Connor because like immediately like
five minutes in he tries to derail and
he's like La didn't you say that Hass
[__] a
17-year-old right so it's like it dude
it's so obvious it's so [__] obvious
what he's to
do so we might watch that after this
okay we might we might I have a lot I I
have a lot okay I have a lot I want to
watch a lot of it older all right A lot
of it older but some of it new okay yeah
yeah you're probably right you're
probably right so uh how's the
documentary coming
along what documentary oh it's uh it's
good obviously taking a few days off
to deal with the old demons surfacing
but do is good uh might I'm either done
with interviews or no I'm not done I'm
very nearly done with interviews and uh
I'm going to start editing uh I think
Monday I think I think I think the plan
is to stop talking about Destiny on
Monday unless you know if he gets
arrested I'll I'll make a comment um
maybe I'll try
to uh cuff the ball of shame to a few
more orbiters ankles if they if they
leave in ways that I think are are
unfair to the victims and everybody but
other than that oh well actually there's
two other things I'm most likely
interviewing
uh someone from the report I don't want
to say who CU I'm not sure if it's going
to happen totally but I think I think it
is um so there will
be who do I think he would be
interviewing who do I think it would be
interviewing my guess would be Anna all
right cuz would he would he say would he
like he could probably get an interview
with lav like really easily I think I
think it's Anna it has to be Anna it has
to be Anna it has to be Anna that's my
guess Molina would it be Molina I
don't I think Molina might be more
interesting
um actually no I don't know I don't know
who'd be more interesting to hear I
think it's I think it's I think it's
Anna Molina would be crazy though I I
did notice
right A lot of people when when Destiny
divorced Molina The Narrative like
quickly changed like a you like super
quick Molina's insane Molina's crazy
Molina is trying to spread lies I'm
gonna Sue Molina Molina's insane
Molina's CRA like it changed really
quick but she wasn't crazy or insane
while they were dating or while they
were married
right but the moment the
moment the moment they divorce suddenly
she's insane so I do find that really
interesting
um I mean the obvious the obvious answer
is uh Destiny is uh uh trying to smear
you know someone so they can't come out
maybe all right he had a manifest yeah
it was [__] crazy it was insane
utterly
insane utterly crazy it I would it I'm
I'm guessing Anna but I wouldn't be
surprised if it was mou podcast about
that or something video and and then the
other thing is I'm writing a um I'm
writing an article about
Destiny this one's only 4,000 words so I
expect all of you to read it for real
this time okay okay and that should be
done tomorrow or or Monday probably
tomorrow
oo New Destiny
article I'm definitely probably tomorrow
but maybe Monday all right I'm going to
go live tomorrow okay I'm going to go
live
tomorrow and probably
Monday I don't know Anna sounds like
she's still currently [__] with D no
no no I don't think
so uh
no she is she was on J STS was she
defending Destiny on J
STS yes
what
no she said they
talked oh that makes me so sad
dude come
on
ah ah
dude she she asked me today if I was
making a video on Destiny
I'm guessing I just can't go to her with
with questions about it
huh I'm guessing I'm just not going to
be able
to ask her questions
about about this stuff I'm kind of just
going to have to watch
streams if she's like on his side
Ah that's
disappointing especially like given
given everything I know that's
disappointing you're mischaracterizing
her because of chat's misinfo if she's
going on jto and saying that she's still
friends with them unless that's like
utterly
fake bro have you tried to get a better
deal deal on these sales so you make
more money
what what better deal on
what I don't think she'll defend him but
she just accepts that's how he is I
don't that's disappointing to me I don't
think you should just settle you
shouldn't just like if someone's [__]
evil don't just be like yeah they're
evil
LOL
right I don't know
Anna said she's friendly with Destiny
but she 100% acknowledged that he's
[__] okay that's nice at least I'll
have to watch the jto does anybody have
a link to that jto conversation we could
just watch that if someone has a link
put it in topics and I'll watch it I see
you um now I have to call you
out
okay where is my pedophile
narrative what's your problem
man um
changed the name of my Memoir to the
pedophile narrative no I'm just kidding
uh the pedophile narrative is a video I
said I was going to make by June of 2022
maybe I said April the first time it's
been a while um and I just keep not
making it I don't know why but this
documentary obviously
is addressing the subject somewhat and
then I think I don't know I don't know
for sure if I'm going to make it but I
think I probably am okay um I think I've
uh I think I've said about everything I
want to say there's only one more thing
actually I remember cuz you know getting
sick of talking about pedophiles is like
getting sick of ice cream you don't
think it's possible but at some point it
starts just a little bit of like I maybe
I don't want to spend another several
months doing this but those narrative
videos don't take that long to make so
you know I'll probably do it okay what's
the last thing you want to say
um it's it's just more okay no this this
is probably not the last thing I
probably have one more thing after okay
but then I got to go next color Okay um
I just remember some more cult [__] like
when you first start your investigation
doie hit you up and he was like oh I
think I have information that Destiny
gra somebody yeah
doie snakes me out like a like a good
cultist does like a good brainwashed
little leming does and he said oh yeah
tell me and then like he released the
DMS and everyone was like woohoo and I
was like so do be lied and then Mr girl
said oh is this true and then he said no
it's not and somehow this is caused for
celebration like this is like a win it's
like you people are sick you people are
crazy like it like it it was a wild time
this is a wild time anybody who still
def defending Destiny you're a wild
[__] I ain't going to lie to you you're
a wild ass [__] but um the last thing I
want to say
did you this is a little a little
awkward yeah maybe okay and it's
public emotional from my rant did I get
emotional from your rant yeah uh is my
camera not on or something no it is so
you asking
yes you mean was I coincidentally crying
while you were
answering I guess that was a d question
I mean if you just want to make sure
yeah I was a little unsure at first
why and genuinely curious um perception
that I a narcissistic self-involved main
character syndrome psycho this is going
to probably rub some people the wrong
way I have trouble identifying myself as
a victim or truly feeling outraged when
I think I've been wronged I I feel that
I have to force myself I'm getting much
better at it but I feel I have to force
myself to feel outrage when um I think
something bad is happening to me and so
I think hearing you voice outrage on my
behalf uh and on other people's behalfs
like this is why when I talk about um
myself being abused emotionally or I
talk about myself being harassed and was
like absolutely horrendous horrendous
horrible harassment I don't I don't
really cry I don't really get that
emotional talking about
that but I noticed this writing the
report the section about
Darius and his dog
I don't know about the Darius and the
dog thing is this I actually I might is
it darius's dog died and
then Destiny made fun of him or blamed
him am I am I correct in
that no it was sick it was
sick he did he needed money for vet
build and Destiny made fun of him Molina
was laughing about the dog
dying
what needed a lot of money to
treat Keem ran over it very sad not the
right dog you're thinking of someone
else's dog check
DMS let's
see let's
see Destiny is a popular political
stream and the resident debate bro
someone who most streamers within a
sphere a is there like a time stamp I'm
supposed to be looking
at
dog uh dog drama boyfriend
bro the dog drama is one of darius's uh
alltime dramas sometime in early 2022
Darius and his girlfriend at the time
sushia were wrapped up in financial
issues when they decided to adopt a
puppy for free unfortunately there's no
such thing as a free lunch and the can9
would end up costing more than intended
as the dog developed parvo to which Aras
ended up forking around 4K to have the
puppy treated but then after that the
dog contracted a virus that is
apparently 90% fatal to dogs Darius was
committed to saving the puppy and needed
around 10K to do so therefore he decided
to a set of a GoFundMe to help raise
some cash to save the poor dog's life
Molina Destiny's girlfriend was not a
fan of this and proclaimed that Darius
was being very irresponsible to adopt a
puppy and that if he didn't have enough
money he should probably just put the
dog
down what no dude that's crazy what the
[__] I don't get it the dog would make a
good dinner yes Food Shops we understand
that you're Asian okay we get the joke
buddy
congrats congrats congrats buddy we get
the joke we get
it did you guys know that I'm Asian did
you guys know that I'm Asian Asian
people eat dogs did you guys know that
I'm actually as like the joke is that I
eat the dog because I'm Asian do you
guys do you guys get the joke do you
guys get the joke do you guys get the
joke we get at Food Shops we get it
buddy all right allegedly at some point
either the dgg chat or darius's own chat
Molina mocked and teased Darius for
having to put the dog down which
infuriated Darius to the point where he
retorted with telling Molina to go to go
to go on alive herself 60k a year we
were doing relatively fine financially
the only reason why things ended up
getting [__] is cuz of probably things
that you you know about or whatever when
like you know and like I literally end
up getting financially really
financially [__] until this month I
don't have like [__] Molina money and
I guess that's where like it seems like
I'm really financially [__] cuz
Molina's like let's go to Aruba let's go
to Dubai and like yeah [__] I don't
have [__] 1,500 [__] dollars to go
[__] buy a flight and she's like how
do you not have that I'm like [__] I I
make like 50k a year I'm a [__] in
[__] inflation based [__] place
she has no understanding of that so it
sounds like a lot more that I'm poor
than I am but I have money to go do
things I can go out the [__] okay
hold on chill firstly uh however train
Rex this this this reads like a bad like
and then train Rex walked into a bar
train Rex came in clutch and donated 10K
to Darius so he could save the dog's
life and luckily that expensive dog is
alive today now there was a g that built
between Molina and Darius and the two
would Clash on Destiny's stream but a
debate about a dog would turn into
something more inherently intrusive
apparently a few weeks before all this
went down Molina and Darius had a
encounter while together this is so I
love this
community I I'm G here okay so you see
Destiny and Molita were on a break and
Darius was also having issues with his
girlfriend sushia so the two decided to
hand
sexual happened but Darius did point out
one night where he and Molina were
sleeping in the same bed while Molina
was wearing the lingerie and From
darius's perspective he claimed that
Molina was pushing her btox into his
crotch Molina admittedly denied this and
the two would debate on stream over that
as well as a situation that happened the
next day where Darius said he was going
to take MDMA but warned Molina that he
may become infatuated with her while on
the substance Molina took this as Darius
confessing his love to her which freaked
Molina out and made everything really
awkward between the two the situation
seemed to be a deep rooted oh thank you
quack thank you buddy I think that's
where we'll start listen this is [__]
vile these people are [__] vile and
and still think about the dog I would
just like start sobbing uncontrollably
so I think that I um not that I don't
advocate for myself or stand up for
myself like obviously I will dude I
listen all right I need to open up to
you guys I need to tell you about the
time that I sobbed uncontrollably all
right I how how old was I let me Google
let me figure out how old I was
this was 2019 this would have been six
years
[Music]
ago um what day did it come out hold
on I I guess it doesn't
matter I would have
been roughly
roughly I would have been 16 15 or 16 I
think listen all right I was watching
How to Train Your Dragon 3
okay and listen I was watching it I
think I was watching it for my birthday
so I probably would have been 16 I was
watching it with my mom cuz my me and my
mom went to the movies for my birthday
okay and I was watching it at the ending
I was like I'm I'm going to cry but I
held it in okay I I held my tears all
right I held my tears and afterwards we
had to
go we had to go to like a hardware store
to get uh not a hardware like a f we we
had to get a new fridge I think a fridge
or a washing machine or some [__] and I
was I was looking at the washing
machines with my family and in the
middle of the department store I start
sobbing because I think about the ending
of How to Train Your Dragon 3 and I'll
hiccup has to give up his Dragon dude I
start [__] I I start crying okay I
start crying in the middle of the
department store because I I think about
how the How to Train Your Dragon 3
ending I held my tears in the theater
okay but the moment I saw the fridges in
the department store I start [__] I
start sobbing you guys seen that [__]
you guys seen that [__]
dude okay awesome awesome awesome movie
all right right ASD can get it okay
Castro Jesus Christ I'm I can be pretty
maybe annoying about calling [__] out um
but so it's it's not an intellectual
thing where I don't see when something
bad's happening to me obviously withi
there times where I also didn't see it
but it's that I don't I don't feel it
and so a lot of my defensiveness of
myself is like out it's like it's like
manufactured outrage it's like it's like
if I were my own child and then
somebody's like beating my child up in
front of me and I'm like that's my kid I
really should do something about this I
don't feel a protective like surge of
rape how do you feel about the live
action
um I don't
care that the characters are like
different races or different hair colors
or whatever than the actual like movie I
don't really care because ultimately if
the acting is good the acting is going
to be good but it feels really
forced right it feels really forced that
asid's a [__] black girl
I don't care that she's black it just
feels forced it feels like they chose
like different race
actors for just it it it doesn't like I
don't give a [__] that she's black it's
just like it doesn't feel like it's it's
going to be good like is she a good
actor I don't know I don't know if she's
a good actor but it just feels so
forced it just feels so forced if it's
good it's good I don't care but it just
feels so [__] forced
they could have used more accurate
actors but they didn't and it's like
okay this just kind of feels it kind of
feels lame it kind of feels like the
movie is going to be [__] and in order
to get people to watch it they have to
drum up controversy so they chose like a
black actor
right I don't know like the one that
you're showing I wish I did um I feel it
for the dog I feel it for pixie and
Cherry but um and obviously uh other you
know I I think I think everybody first
kind of saw it with LA my call with LA
where I became very emotional hearing
about how she'd been treated even though
it's kind of similar to how I've been
treated but hearing it seeing it happen
to
her I I can just feel it much more
clearly so I think that's why I see I
think it's something I should work on I
don't I don't think this is like a great
quality of um that I don't feel that but
well if I may I think um I think
obviously too much in One Direction is
not good but um I think being able to
maintain a level head while people are
like saying heinous things about you um
probably have served you well to a
certain degree yeah because of the
nature of the content that you make like
it'll be a lot more difficult for people
to take you seriously even though it's
difficult already when a file after the
cu's review if you're like screaming and
crying not being one true I I think
there's a benefit to it but I um I I
would like to be able to if I could
regulate those emotions but still feel
them when I talk about Pixie and Cherry
I am disregulated I cannot control my
emotions or um I can control what I'm
saying still but I obviously uh can't
like handle it so I get what you're
saying nobody wants to watch me make a a
horribly provocative and offensive video
and then break down crying when people
criticize it so I I'm not working on
that but um you're working on just being
able to feel it at all well I don't know
that would be interesting though I make
a horrible provocative video that I know
is going to make me look like a
pedophile and then I go on streams where
people call me pedophile and I just sub
uncontrollably I could see that working
too for my career I don't know it's a
different trajectory but it's something
I am open to exploring it' definitely be
funny that would be funny I agree I
agree Benny I mean me crying right now
is funny it's funny that people are like
he's making this all about himself he's
the main character and I go stream and
start crying about it that's that is
funny all right I gota go to the next
caller all right see you later see
you
um I got to blow my
nose I have two reasons to keep tissues
in my office but I still don't have any
uh I'll be back in a second all
right they're making a case that outside
of Destiny really sipping in his own mck
here uh it's probably like at least 10
or 20 so-called orbiters I guess you
would say or uh Destiny career makers
that probably going to be cooked after
this um and I wanted to start with her
because in my best
estimation um destiny seems to have
personally I think this isn't a bigest
scand let me start with that uh your Mr
girl report on him was like riddled with
at least five other things I can think
of anything from like B kid to Blue te
um I think the deeper problem on a
more per of level in terms of who
Destiny is the person I don't want to go
back because I don't want to miss the
time stamp that I already jumped to but
I what is he blue te I feel like the
blue te stuff is relatively relevant I
don't understand what he's uh exactly
what he's
referencing like theum whatever I think
that's pretty stupid just just even
talking about that element of it uh he's
a manipulative isn't even the right word
he's very good at implementing which
seems like probably some level to I
think you call it psychopathy to you
essentially you think you think it's
stupid to talk about him violating the
consent of these women
why no no no I'm completely on your side
yeah but you said stupid to talk about
uh yeah because what why
okay well when you say that it sounds
like you're not on my side because
that's my side I said we should talk
about that not that we can't talk about
anything else but I just think
minimizing sexually predatory behavior
criminal sex crimes I I don't want to
minimize sex
crimes um kind of but like okay okay so
let me let me start here you admit that
there are things in your original report
that probably far outweigh this quote
unquote Scandal that seems to be cooking
in pretty bad this time right far
outweigh far like 10 times yeah at least
if this okay on a scale one
I I don't want to do this I don't want
victims of predatory behavior to listen
to you casually come up with a rating
system and talk about stuff that you
think outweighs their Agony by a factor
of 10 I don't want to do this so what
what is your point that that we already
knew things that you think are worse and
you're asking me if I think they're
worse I don't know it's all to me really
bad and I don't see a utility in
comparing the Badness of each thing to
me it's all they're all just part of the
same
picture okay didan send you the video I
sent to you
vet if not I can send it to you right
now like a minute and a half
uh to vet yeah well good I think they
were
screening do you want me to play a video
yeah what is it I don't think I want to
play video what is
it uh okay so let me reduce down my
original point and then you decide if
you want to play the video Destiny has a
in my opinion a particularly worse uh
effect not so much as crimes or legality
but he has an ability
[Music]
to two out of the three callers here
have been
atrocious I'm hopefully it gets
better almost invert reality at will uh
there was a person like I said I link
this you don't have to play it but there
was a person like years ago who i s uh
there was a person years ago who went on
Destiny screen and he does these sort of
casual call outs where it'll be like
disagree with me on my take on why
cheese pizza is better than pepperoni or
why Star Wars one and Star Wars 2 and in
this video you can see it in real time
the same foundational tactic that he's
implementing here that's not working
because too many people hate him uh but
he goes on a minute and a half long fit
with this guy in a video about something
as simple as when the weekend after
Nexus which d the same person you'd say
this week is this weekend the weekend
after that is the weekend after next he
has an ability to um it's not
manipulation so much as it is have you
ever done a talent show before a talent
show a talent show yeah
no well I assume when you first came on
to the scene maybe your first live
stream or whatever there was a degree of
uh self-doubt being in the spotlight
with this sort of planet of audience
that it now come into your liking but
with some King maker determining who's
right and who's wrong call it narrative
control yeah I didn't self out
no I don't think
so okay maybe it's maybe it's not you I
have self-doubt just I don't think I
felt self-doubt about stream okay that's
cool Destiny is able to have sort of a
reverse I think he calls it Emperor has
no clothes but he'll convince you that
the emperor with clothes on actually
doesn't have clo um and as bad as the
effects of this have born out to be in
this particular instance when you're
able to mass indoctrinate your fan BAS
Community into believing that a
15-year-old and his father are
essentially fair game and sort of a
vigilante justice uh you're talking
about his plan to kill the Doo the doo
kid and his father because he was
interrupting streams personally
personally I would use like conspiracy
to commit dou homicide being super
specific but because when we say plan to
kill it's not like you know all girls
literally actual addresses times who
knows what yeah
um can I ask you another question it's
related you haven't asked me any
question
where's another okay then I'll ask you
the first question okay do you you think
people I have no idea but um I think he
would what do you think Destiny has
killed people are you [__]
what you think Destiny's killed people
before
dud
wow
dude awesome stuff I'd kill myself if I
met Destiny
IRL and
okay so basically he has true okay I
mean hey I can't argue with the facts
point is I don't think he actually is a
psychopath um I don't know the pathology
but Destiny seems like a very uh
vindictive but a cold vindictive person
on essentially any issue uh over the
past two months I don't know who's
watching been following this feels like
it's Meandering a lot and I want us to
focus up can you just say the thing that
you think because uh it feels like we're
going all over the place and in a way
that feels a little
irresponsible irresponsible
how well again like I said the stream
think Destin is dangerous though correct
yeah I mean yeah he again it's just
coming out that he's secretly recording
people while they have sex if that's
true and I believe it is then that makes
him dangerous and he's planing to kill
somebody which I wrote about that makes
him dangerous he's done a lot of things
that I would I would make would make me
think he's dangerous
yes but the common threat isn't that
he's dangerous
right like there's a reason behind it
he's not just willfully
sadistic I think okay
he's Maniac he's not a murderous
psychopath what is your point dude you
got get thank [__] dude what is this
that's your point or we got to get the
next call cuz I
this is your last attempt to say what
your point
is I don't know I'm just trying to
figure out if this is Harry Potter one
or
7 okay well thanks for calling in uh
okay all right um we're going to tighten
this up a lot so from now on if you get
in the call and you don't know what
you're talking about as defined by me if
I think you don't know what you're
talking about we got just we just have
to go to the next person
I have completely new info and would
like to share it on stream
uh no you can DM me something if you
want um if it's not made public it's
likely I will not make it public
here dude why holy [__] there's so many
[__] retards on today what is this
what is this this is not a gladiatorial
I know the I know the title of the
stream and it's probably my fault this
is not supposed to be like a
gladiatorial entertaining drama show I
want to talk about what's happened about
my feelings and thoughts people's
changing feelings and thoughts and sort
of um try to do some repair repair yes
my reputation um try to shepher what's
happening into a responsible Direction
where I can see pixie and Cherry and any
other victims line is probably my least
favorite I think
um I
think the hotline can be
good if you get a good
caller however I do
think the what was the therapy [__]
called that he used to do he would like
Mr girl the whatever the [__]
right like that [__] I I like that
because it was it was like you would
come in with something pointed yeah
advice and confessions you'd come in
with something
pointed and you'd have a serious
discussion about it and it would be very
very in my opinion interesting to listen
to right I did I did enjoy that show I
didn't listen to much of it to be fair
um you know I did
uh I did like what I
heard we might watch a little bit of
that maybe not today but
eventually eventually we will
I think all
right yeah I agree to you uh hold
Destiny accountable and uh I want to
help people who are questioning or
confused or angry or um about about like
what's happening about the rug being
pulled out from underneath them who feel
betrayed by Destiny I want to help them
like process what's happening or help us
all process I guess I guess that's what
it is it's a processing stream not a oh
my God another plane hit the towers
thing I I don't I don't want to do that
okay hello hello Mr Carson
hello so Destiny is a criminal and Benny
is right all of his fans knew and they
didn't
care so the rest of this not he's never
been charged or charged with a crime as
far as I know so I don't know if we can
call him a criminal or he's never been
convicted of a crime I believe he he
self admitted to things that are a crime
is that not the case saying you did a
crime doesn't make you a criminal in a
journalistic sense true how can see that
so I want to talk about orbits okay and
uh the rest might have already occurred
to you so interrupt me if I'm talking
[__] that you already know okay like I
said Benny is right all of his fans
don't care the real ones the ones that
post on Reddit all acting all shocked uh
are either faking or uh something is
going on
there and this means to that uh he gets
to keep having a stream and he gets to
keep having
influence it's possible he even gets
invited on to things in a couple months
and uh I want to talk about attacking
his
orbiters uh I think you should keep
doing that I think his orbiters are
accessories to criminal behavior and
that one of the ways you can permanently
harm him is to make it seem unattractive
to be a destiny
Orbiter so for example going after Pisco
going after cran Anna uh going after
NATO aidite especially NATO aidite given
that she was directly involved in trying
to talk down um the primary victim in
this case from I think I think warning
people I I said this before but those
when you're cave diving you know when
you go cave diving and you probably seen
a memes where there's a sign that's like
if you go past the sign without cave
diving training you were going to die so
I've had nightmares about cave diving
where I get stuck like that poor fool
who was upside
down these are quickly I'm getting
uninterested in this we might move on
all right we might skip ahead or move on
but very quickly I'm getting a little
uninterested in these callers okay hours
with this that's that was just caving
this is cave diving okay caving caving
is dangerous don't get me wrong caving
is dangerous cave diving that's that's a
whole another thing brother that's a
whole another thing see I see can he
calls in okay that's awesome oh
yeah yeah yeah you you could pay me
enough money okay well so if you look up
they they have they'll go down there and
and put a sign there that's like if you
don't have proper training equipment and
you go like the stream guys that is true
okay 150 people watching 70 likes 80 of
you 80
individuals sitting at home watching
this [__] stream
freeloading all right I don't even care
you don't even have to donate I love
your money all right donate if you would
like to I'm I'm insanely appreciative
for all the donos you guys are willing
to bestow upon me but come
on come on guys
guys come on all
right come on like the stream okay like
the stream thank you sign you will
you're going to die a horrible death and
I want that's what I was thinking when I
wrote the destiny report I want that to
just be like anybody who's like I'm
hearing blue te What's d what is this
what what is that I want people to be
like this is a sign it's a really big
sign it takes a while to read but it's
it's a full ass sign that says don't and
I'm not I've never thought of that as
like this will really harm Destiny or or
you know cut off his ability to gain
power whatever it's more like you I
don't want I don't want to see people
end up like me or or or I don't want
yeah you what's happening to a right now
the decision she's having to make you
don't want that to happen to you it
sucks uh no that appears to be a living
nightmare
hellscape yeah the cognitive dissonance
she must be experiencing is like insane
and like so I've Mi feelings about it
obviously have anger towards her but I
also have
like empathy for the the awful position
sheon okay so yeah I have empathy for
Kyla I guess that's in character for
you so the other thing sorry were you
I'm going to bring something else up no
so the other thing I want to talk about
is your
orbit you've got a
problem okay which uh you've actually
touched on earlier which is it felt
really good to be accepted to be able to
say the [__] you do and not get uh
suspended from school or arrested or
yeah
damn so Ed for talking is a wild feeling
though I will admit I actually read that
story about you way before I knew it and
my opinion of you in that moment was
pretty negative yeah I was not to happy
with theow in that case yeah basically
we're total [__] about it they were
they were and they like like you're
journalist you don't care about free
speech like [__] you you throw me under
the bus so I'm get arrested for talking
[__] you but this stream is really
supposed to be about like what's
happening with Destiny and so if you
want to bring up my problem with my
orbiters let's keep it really brief all
right
actually like Cas I don't need to talk
about it um some other time thank you
for the time thanks for
calling curious all right is the next
call going to be Kenny hopefully maybe
Noto aite unfollowed
Destiny that's good but that's like
movie star shade you
know Aubrey Plaza unfollowed whatever
I want to
see a clean
break a concise statement that does not
mention president
Sunday or anyone but Destiny and
possibly some victims that that
concisely states and condemns his
behavior and what she's going to do
about
it Smith says I'm not an Orbiter
activate the tractor beam full
power wow awesome stuff awesome
stuff truly hello how you doing man okay
how are you I'm doing good doing good um
so how you doing throughout this whole
[__] show uh well like I said it's been
very emotional a lot of mixed
feelings it's been a lot to deal with I
think for for all of us really not just
me it seems like you know obviously the
victims but even a lot of the fans that
are leaving I think feel really betrayed
and rug pulled and seems like
everybody's going through a lot right
now yeah yeah no I agree um just before
I get into my question you mentioned
something this other guy this other
darus uh and his dog I didn't hear about
that story I actually read your report
um I'm just wondering what what was
going on with that if you don't talking
about it why don't you read the [__]
report There's a summary section yeah
it's about and it tells you everything
that Destiny did in one page okay it
will take you
probably based on screenshots and
recordings um the interviews I did were
mostly about um getting people to give
me screenshots and recordings and
getting getting people to tell me their
perspective make sure I'm not like
misunderstanding stuff um um well what
do you think of
Sunday silence
um her
career I don't think that's the case
either yeah you're saying cutting off
personally versus professionally yeah
personally person Kenny Kenny I mean
yeah he could
just thank you for calling Mr girl
hotline how can I help
you Kenny you're muted Kenny you're
muted Kenny you're muted Kenny Nathan
this guy's
muted
Kenny then stop explaining their
motivations
okay no don't stop it's interesting and
it gives us something to mull
over
hny where is he [__] they're also
telling her a lie that it could be kept
secret [__] [__] [__] [__] Kenny no
Kenny
[__] just enter you know get get a legal
settlement that says that she won't sue
him and then smear her you know or do
whatever not the kind of person you want
to
trust hello hello
KY uh so what I want to talk about is
like you know D like a stream on
anything else and I'm just interested in
what's your thought thought about um
like cutting people off like like um It
Feels Like A D aidite like think like
think like it's a good thing to keep see
as a friend even though after all what
he
did like I feel
like yeah yeah you're saying cutting off
personally versus professionally yeah
personally
person um you're asking if I would cut
someone off if they behave this way or
what are you ask no no like a more
general question like when should you
cut a friend
off I guess when you want to or feel the
relationship's bad for you I mean
there's still a way to be um friends
with Destiny if you're aidite but he's
got to be like Hannibal Lector like
you're not going to trust him with
anything no Financial ties you're not
going to say anything to him in private
that you're not comfortable being heard
in public if you want to make him like
your project of like I want to
rehabilitate the psychopath and assuming
he's interested in that then you know I
think it's it's fine to keep in touch
with somebody it's fine it's fine to
have a pen pal who's like a serial
killer in prison
like um I I don't but it depends on like
what what the Friendship consists of
like if you're aware of him committing
more crimes not telling
anyone um yeah I'm thinking after the
Kenny call in we we move on to other
content we've been going for almost
three hours okay I just feel like
they're being disingenous like both D ER
was like I'll give him one more chance
even after all all that he's done I just
feel like I feel like there's something
more to it than uh them just being like
Dan said like he's friends he's my
friend for 15 years I'm not going to
come off after just that I believe it's
maral and I'll give another yeah I just
feel like he's
lying
maybe I I think it it does seem like if
if five more victims come forward Dan
will probably still be his friend I
think you're right but again
I uh I don't really want to speculate
about this even though I just did like
who not who cares but I just don't think
it's um really pressing to talk about
because again it's a weird confusing
situation for them and they're in denial
I think they're in a cult so like I
don't put a whole I think it's I think
they're enabling an abuser with these
statements as far as like what's best
for them personally I just don't think
it's super relevant to talk about right
now and I don't want to okay like have
you seen uh desy's like recent DD log of
him like going after
everybody um from a couple days
ago yeah yeah like how do you feel about
that you think like like why maybe I'm
just like perplexed I'm like why he's
doing why he's doing this he just he
doesn't need to say anything
um this is some some of what U my my new
article is going to be about but I think
what he's doing is taking some of the
anger at him that comes from the
cognitive dissonance of admiring this
person thinking he's going to save
American democracy by being an next Joe
Rogan and feeling betrayed by him and
seeing that he really is not who he says
he is and I think that makes that
creates anger rage and and cognitive
dissonance and I think that he redirects
that anger at other people and so every
Destiny controversy every time Destiny
does something that is questionable or
immoral there's always a villain every
story about Destiny doing something
wrong has a villain who is worse than
Destiny and that villain becomes the
target so you say Destiny leaks blue te
nudes the immediate responses well then
she went on Twitter she she she hacked
into his Twitter posted a picture of his
dick and locked him out of his Twitter
which is true but that doesn't change
what he did it doesn't change what kind
of person he is also which of these two
people am I going to trust someone who
leaks nudes just for fun or someone who
when she gets her nudes leaked she
steals your Twitter and posts a picture
of your dick like the second one I'm
like I kind of I kind of want to be
friends with blue te hearing that makes
want to be friends with her more than
than I did before I heard it so but but
in the in the destiny you know narrative
explanation of this AG it's okay that he
did that because of what she did and
there's there's listen what blue T did
was [__] based Destiny [__]
deserved it Destiny is a scumbag rotten
piece of [__] okay definitively a rotten
sack of [__] and he deserved the blue T
[__] A
th% deserved
and when I I'm about to say something
and I know the [__] the main reaction
is going to be oh was [__] 2012 it
was a different time whatever I don't
give a [__] all right I don't give a
[__] okay D's reaction the whole dicks
out for Destiny movement [__]
vile the fact that this guy's entire
audience I'm paraphrasing I know it
wasn't every single person but the fact
that this guy's entire [__] audience
that this guy's entire Community saw
what happened and instead of saying oh
you leaked a girls nuds that's weird
they all sided with him and posted their
[__] in
solidarity imagine being a victim of
something so [__] heinous as having
some of the most private thing you could
ever have ever that stuff gets leaked
right you're a victim of that you're a
victim of essentially Revenge
porn and then everybody sides with the
person who leaked your
nudes [__] disgusting I don't give a
[__] that it was 2012 I don't care that
it was a different time I don't care
that it was a different era of the
internet
absolutely [__]
vile and I don't give a [__]
people like that is why people supported
him through that is mindboggling I don't
care if they supported him after it okay
if it's one [__] up if it's just once
and it never happens again sure I don't
care but it's happened like this weird
sex [__] has happened so much so often
over 10 years [__] crazy that people
supported him at all through that
[__] insane always an explanation of
that so I think this has just worked
really well for for him in the past I
think it'll work with the core core core
base that I can shoot someone Fifth
Avenue base and you see Trump do the
same thing when Trump is accused of
doing something immoral or wrong he will
come up with stupid lame nicknames for
people I'm Mr rapist and
then juw soccer give you give you your
marching orders don't criticize me go
harass these people they're the bad
they're the bad guys and it's the same
it's really easy to see when if you're
not a trump supporter when you and I
think most Destiny fans at this point
are probably not Trump supporters so you
see um Trump do the same thing comes up
with a nicknames the supporters have
cognitive distance because he is not who
he says he is he's not who they who they
think he is it's really plain to see if
you're not like in the cult and then uh
all of that anger which should be at him
for disappointing them is all redirected
at whoever Nancy
Pelosi
laugh yeah one last thing yeah you know
Destiny was always going about I want to
make my community more like like woman
friendly right like obviously I I didn't
buy it because he the stuff he does like
but now this like I think people are
waking up but on a on a Destin Community
tter people are like we still like
follow Destiny after this like this will
pass I'm like
I don't think you could be a female D
anymore after this I I think this like
too much like after all these warning
signs after all these events this has to
be a Breaking Point like d has to be D
has to be like a boys club Only
now um I think there will still be women
who are
interested okay thanks for the call in
but I I don't mean to demean those women
I'm saying that okay um W Kenny W
Kenny part of what creates this power
imbalance is the the kingmaker nature of
Destiny like there are women who don't
care if sexual videos of themselves get
out they're women who do porn so say
you're an only fans Creator and you're
like so I have sex with this guy and he
sends the video around and I get you
know thousands of dollars per month
added to my income like [__] it whatever
like I I
uh
there if people like Destiny and Harvey
Weinstein where carpet cleaners for
example they would not get away with
what they get away with they would not
be able to victimize people and this is
often reframed as greed victims are
greedy Ashley Jud is greedy because she
wanted to be a movie star rose mcau is
greedy that's why that's why she was
there why are you meeting Harvey
Weinstein in a hotel room anyway because
you want money you greedy [__] but
everybody wants money everybody needs
money that's capitalism you have to make
money what is more appealing than the
idea of being able to be safe well-liked
famous powerful you have these things
dangled in front of you and but it's not
it's not like a bag of gold being
dangled in front of you a bag of gold is
a bag of food that's housing that's
medical bills that's your parents
medical bills that's a car that's
Freedom that's time that's retirement
that's your kids's college education
that is what is being dangled in front
of you and that is why you ignore
warning signs of sexual predation and
that is why when you are predated upon
you start coming up with ways to
rationalize what's happening and and go
into denial and that's why when you see
it happening to other people you're like
well maybe I can broker some kind of
deal since they're both my friends it's
it's the denial of the power
differential and the structure of the
system and the structure of the cult
so given all that like the The Lure is
still there I think more women will
become ins sared they might think well I
can handle it I'm smart I'm funny and
then find out that Destiny is about
10,000 times more malicious and
Psychopathic than they thought hearing
these stories even now so I don't think
it's like you can't be a female dger I
do think you can't be safe as a female
dger but I don't think it'll be like
obviously there'll probably a drop in
the number of women that are that want
to watch this [__] but as far as
orbiters and and women who just you
look at Michael Jackson an obvious
pedophile Obvious Child
Blaster
what no
no not Michael Jackson what
what I've been saying this [__] bro I've
been [__] saying this [__] okay
Michael Jackson why the [__] why the
[__] would a grown adult want to sleep
in a bed with little kids [__]
weird insane
weird oh I'm actually like mentally 12
I'm calling you and I want your kid to
come to my Ranch where he's going to
sleep in the same bed as
me [__] dude Michael Jackson is a freak
Michael Jackson is a freak and you know
what I'll [__] say it okay I'll
[__] say it all right his music not
even that
good not even that
good his music I'll I'll even go a
little further his music is
[__] his music is
shed all
right the only people who like Michael
Jackson are [__] black people who
grew up in the suburbs and white women
who are insecure that is the only people
who like that dog [__] [__] music all
right
all
right and I'll [__] say it I'll
[__] say it all right blacks who grew
up in the suburbs with no fear for their
lives they were [__] slinging drugs
on the curb side of [__] Avenue 14th
or whatever the [__] there are the
people that listen to Michael jackon
you're going to trust someone who
listens to that [__] come on bro come on
bro Jesus
Christ Jesus Christ those aren't
suburbs I'm the white the white
neighborhoods the only blacks who listen
to Michael Jackson are the blacks who
grew up in these Suburban areas full of
white people and no fear for they
lives all
right the only blacks who be listening
to Michael Jackson are the blacks who
ain't have to sling nothing on the
corner of 15th and Avenue all
right and I'll [__] say it
again I'll say it so you can [__]
hear me okay whitewashed blacks listen
to Michael Jackson so they can feel more
black when in reality they're trying to
[__] assimilate with white culture
okay thank you awesome sauce for the $5
black woman flexing saying BL B boss
thank you thank you appreciate it thank
you like fandom money
power are really powerful and so I don't
I don't mean to [__] you future female
ders or destiny fans but yeah I I think
they there will still be
more all right that's all I have thanks
you're welcome
thank you oomy thank you thank
you capitalism is cringe yeah I've got
problems with capitalism and this is one
of them that you have to make money for
food but what's even worse is the
framing of wanting money like if we're
going to be capitalist that's fine but
then don't call wanting money
greed I get that at certain point it's
like you want more than your share so
like yes I billionaires I'm fine with
calling greedy at a certain point once
like Mar showing his racism werewolf
Clan
hide user on channel join the Discord
and tell me how any of that was racist
and you will be
unbanned all right join the Discord and
tell me how any of that is racist and
you will be unhidden from the chat okay
all
right all
right you you have enough money so that
your family is going to be rich until
the end of the human race like that's
that's great but
the people like people at Kyla's level
like she wants [__] security it's a
it's a threat her her future and current
livelihood are being threatened like
that's her safety it's literally safety
money becomes safety and then when you
want safety all right I'm guessing I
kind of want to stop here I'll I'll skip
ahead like a little
bit whoa but right now you I think the
pretty much all the orbiters are making
do sound [__] insane and delusional
to varying degrees and yeah it's like
they can't stop thinking in ways that
benefit Destiny even when they're trying
to get out they it's like they can't and
I think I think the fantasy is like we
we'll just each take a chunk of dgg
we'll keep our piece of
audience I I that's not it's not good
you got to just
say me out the
bus what's he doing live let's see I
appreciate that um if I see hypocrisy in
somebody who's calling out Destiny right
now do you think it's best to wait um on
calling that out or should I say
something sooner
I think that calling it out runs the
risk of making a false equivalence I
don't know who you're talking about but
I'm guessing that they thank you lumpy
Willie for the
399 Doge gifting a bone a bone a
bone with a ribbon thank you thank you
are not as bad as Destiny in on whatever
Dimension you think they're being
hypocritical I don't think you need to
necessarily be silent but all right I
think we're done with this um I'll keep
it up and if something interesting
happens I'll watch it but I do have the
quack graciously thank you quack sent me
the timestamp for when Anna speaks about
Destiny I do want to watch this